80 prozent aller menschen in deutschland
sagen das ist dass nutella heißt und
nicht die nutella woher wir das wissen
ist doch klar ich habe hier so eine
kleine umfrage gemacht und da haben ein
paar leute mitgemacht die zahlen lügen
nicht okay unsere frage ist natürlich
absolut nicht seriös aber genau das
zeigt das problem gefühlt überall online
auf jeder webseite draußen auf der
straße überall werden wir nach unserer
meinung gefragt und es entstehen um
fragen der who
oder doch eher daumen runter wie kann
man erkennen doch meinungsumfragen gut
und repräsentativ sind und wie feldmann
nicht auf schlechte rein das zeigen wir
euch jetzt
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
politbarometer to go und gleich zu
beginn könnt ihr uns in den kommentaren
schreiben ob ihr meinungsumfragen
generell vertraut so ganz nach eurem
gefühl ja nein in drei schritten gibt es
hier alle umfrage basics die ihr wissen
löst erstens wie sind professionelle
meinungsumfragen entstanden zweitens wie
erkennt man schlechte umfragen und
drittens was macht gute umfragen aus
ganz entscheidend bei umfragen ist der
wird eigentlich befragt es kommt eben
nicht nur darauf an wie viele menschen
befragt werden sondern auch darauf dass
die befragten die bevölkerung
verhältnismäßig widerspiegeln das nennt
man repräsentativität im extremfall kann
sogar eine umfrage mit weniger leuten
genauer sein dass eine umfrage mit mehr
leuten lasst uns an dieser stelle mal
zusammen in eine zeit abzusteigen und
ist ja 1936 in die usa reisen ich bin
geschichtsverein ich bin so was immer
spannend also es sind
präsidentschaftswahlen in den usa der
republikaner lehnen tritt gegen den
demokraten roosevelt an die zeitung
ribéry digest galt damals als nahezu
unfehlbarer den wahlsieger vorherzusagen
schon fünf mal hatte sie den ausgang
richtig prognostiziert wie hat diese
zeitung das gemacht na ja sie hat aber
millionen stimmzettel verschickt und sie
hat leute angerufen insgesamt zehn
millionen menschen wurden kontaktiert
genau genommen wurden leute kontaktiert
die erst autobesitzer registriert waren
und dabei kamen dann rund 2,4 millionen
antworten heraus
eben nicht kein like die unfehlbare
zeitung irrte und sagt er den falschen
sieger voraus die prognostizierten stadt
roosevelt vielleicht könnt ihr euch auch
schon denken was der große haken bei der
umfrage war nämlich dass fast nur
autobesitzer befragt wurden die meisten
die sich damals ein auto oder ein
telefon leisten konnten waren eher
anhänger der republikaner ein bisschen
besser ist es bei einem findigen
sozialwissenschaftler abgelaufen der
damals die demoskopie die bühne betrat
george gallup und sein damals neu
gegründete das
meinungsforschungsinstitut geht einen
anderen weg sie befragten weitaus
weniger menschen rund 50.000 in face to
face interviews und haben dabei aber
versucht darauf zu achten dass die
auswahl der personen die
gesamtbevölkerung widerspiegelt seine
prognose am ende war richtig und für
viele der durchbruch der quoten
stichprobe wenn also das stimmungsbild
der bevölkerung korrekt dargestellt
werden soll dann muss die auswahl die
befragt wird die stichprobe die
bevölkerung auch exakt abbilden in den
notwendigen punkten also bei dingen wie
den bildungs card beim einkommen beim
wohnort und bei vielen anderen sachen so
und jetzt zurück in die gegenwart und
zur frage wie erkennen wir unseriöse
umfragen spielen wir das mal durch los
geht's ihr seid am smartphone und lest
euch auf einer nachrichtenseite einen
artikel durch es geht um klima und
wirtschaftsminister habeck und neue
klimamassnahmen in der mitte des
artikels taucht eine umfrage auf wenn
man den anbieter mal pauli und jetzt
werdet ihr auf einmal zum klimaschutz
befragt und da klingelt der umfrage
alarm schon direkt das problem nennt
sich selbst rekrutierung also die
auswahl wird direkt von den teilnehmern
bestimmt pauli ist nicht auf mich
zugekommen hat sich nicht bei euch
gemeldet sondern in dem teil weil ihr es
einfach vorgeschlagen bekommt und zwar
wie alle teilnehmenden die auf einem
nachrichten portal für nachhaltigkeit
waren damit wiederum gehört ihr zu einer
bestimmten gruppe die so wenig
repräsentativ für die gesamtbevölkerung
ist wie alle autobesitzer ihr
interessiert euch general schon fürs
klima für politik da seid ihr ja die
nach webseite auch jung und so weiter
und so fort das grenzt euch ein und
macht euch dann insgesamt nicht
repräsentativ außerdem gerade bei so
offen zu ähnlichen politischen oder
umstrittenen umfragen können solche
online umfragen auch schnell gekapert
werden gruppen parteien oder
parteianhänger die eine umfrage zu ihren
gunsten entscheiden wollen die helfen
nach sie rufen dazu auf an der umfrage
mit einer bestimmten antwort
teilzunehmen und können das ergebnis
damit massiv beeinflussen naja und auch
ohne aufruf haben manche an bestimmten
themen eben mehr interesse als andere
wie das konkret zum problem werden kann
das erklärt herr jung vor ein paar
jahren gab es situationen gesten die
frage soll die sommerzeit die
internetseite bestellt werden er hat im
europäischen kontext würde da eine freie
umfrage aufgesetzt bei der jeder
teilnehmen konnte dann war viele waren
überrascht über die ergebnisse weil
natürlich zum beispiel die landwirte die
ein großes interesse haben dass sie
wegen ihrer tiere nicht die zeit
umstellen wollen sich der massenhaft
daran mit panik geraten wenn die
menschen die ganz zufrieden sind mit der
sommerzeit und der winter zeitumstellung
überhaupt nicht auf die idee gekommen
sind an der befragung teil zu sehen wenn
sie etwas später nicht methodisch
ausgeglichen wird dann ist das ein
riesenproblem um ein aussagekräftiges
stimmungsbild zu haben so und jetzt noch
mal zurück zu pauli ihr habt jetzt vor
allem drei minuten damit verbracht diese
umfrage auszufüllen das sind genau drei
minuten mehr die ihr auch dieser seite
unterwegs war die ihr dort verbracht
habt und wenn ihr ohne umfrage dort
gewesen wärt werden drei minuten weniger
gewesen ihr wisst sicher dass dinge wie
die verweildauer hier auf youtube aber
auch für webseiten wichtig sind um so in
der relevanten suchmaschinen
aufzusteigen und solche umfragen helfen
natürlich und haben somit nicht nur
einen ich sag mal wissenschaftlichen
nutzen sondern auch einen
wirtschaftlichen denn je länger man auf
einer seite ist desto mehr werbung
bekommt mal angezeigt und desto mehr
bekommt der betreiber der seite auch das
ist ein kritikpunkt dafür hat tolle
jetzt ein richtig tolles umfrageergebnis
92 96 prozent der bürger sind für
massive klimaschutz lassen haben da
schreibt er nicht nur die nachrichten
website sondern viele andere dann so
eine schlagzeile klickt sich einfach gut
die umfrageergebnisse in eine große
buchstaben in eine überschrift
reinpassen es sind sehr oft daneben halt
des aha effekt oder das dessau forschung
der schlagzeile wegen gemacht worden
danach sollte der umfrage alarm dann
sofort an die die spektakulärsten
einfachsten ergebnisse sind oft die
kritik würdigsten und wir merken auch
immer wieder wie viele einschränkungen
es bei seriösen umfragen gibt bei
unseren recherchen für diese videoreihe
sprechen wir vorab mit der
forschungsgruppe wahlen und die betont
dann immer wieder was man eben genau
nicht aus einer umfrage ableiten kann
und wenn ihr dann stattdessen auf einer
seite ein ergebnis seht und da auch noch
nachkommastellen angegeben sind dann
wird seit vorsichtiges große deutsche
tageszeitung werden umfrageergebnisse
werden mit dezimalstellen veröffentlicht
das ist natürlich angesichts von vieler
marken von müssten minus drei
prozentpunkten auf ein bild um die
gemessenen wert totale wahnsinn weil die
genauigkeit suggeriert wird die keinen
sinn macht auch schwierig wenn ihr seht
war bei poldi zum beispiel eine umfrage
in auftrag gegeben hat war es eventuell
sogar ein klimaschutz verein in unserem
beispiel also achtet da immer auf
interessenkonflikte
das gilt übrigens auch für
wissenschaftliche studien
manchmal stecken unternehmen dahinter
die ein bestimmtes ziel erreichen wollen
also die umfrage muss nicht unbedingt
schlecht sein viele auftraggeber sind da
absolut neutral und an einem seriösen
ergebnis interessiert manche können beim
ergebnis aber auch nachhelfen zum
beispiel durch suggestivfragen die die
befragten schon in eine bestimmte
richtung lenken können wie zb hier wenn
ich damit starte viele menschen sind ja
auch passend das was meinen sie dann
bringe ich schon damit einen touch
schreien weil eine ganze menge von
menschen eben auch sich daran
orientieren was eine mehrheit ok so viel
jetzt zu den schlechten umfragen aber
kommen wir jetzt mal zu den dingen die
gute umfragen auszeichnet wie erkennt
man jetzt diese repräsentativität und
seriosität eines vorweg selbst für
profis ist dass ab und an nicht einfach
das ist beruhigend hilft uns natürlich
aber erstmal nicht so wirklich weiter
aber keine sorge es gibt da einige
punkte die er beachten könnt als erste
ist zb die auswahl der befragten die
dahinter steckt die haben ja vorher
schon die selbstregulierung angeschaut
besser ist die sogenannte
zufallsstichprobe auf die ihr achten
könnt wie zum beispiel per telefonanruf
so macht es die forschungsgruppe wahlen
hatte machte nutzen wir telefonische
befragungen die aus zwei
unterschiedlichen
teilen bestehen nämlich einmal einer
zufallsstichprobe aus nunmal des
festnetzes und einer zufallsstichprobe
aus nummer eines mobilfunknetzes und
des disney ist hat natürlich den großen
vorteil ist man über die vorwahl auch
eine regionale zuordnung vornehmen kann
mehr zu dem auswahlverfahren haben wir
euch auch schon mal in einem video
erklärt das findet ihr wenn ihr oben auf
das klingt es geht darin um das
politikerranking des politbarometers und
wie das genau entsteht ob es sich um
eine zufallsstichprobe handelt könnt ihr
gut nachlesen in den quellen der umfrage
so wie hier beim politbarometer
da steht dann auch genau wie viele
menschen teilgenommen haben und wie sie
erreicht wurde generell sind
transparente quellen und datensätze
wirklich wichtig nicht nur bei umfragen
sondern auch an anderer stelle wenn
nichts zu verbergen hat der legt auch
alles offen da kann man den alarm dann
schon wieder aus drehen oder zumindest
ein bisschen entspannter sein ansonsten
eben die vorher schon angesprochenen
punkte auftraggeber checken und auf
interessenkonflikte achten auf die
fragen schauen sind sie neutral keine
suggestivfragen auf mehr schauen heißt
die überschrift und sich nicht locken
lassen dann direkt was teilen nur wenn
man das irgendwie toll findet also immer
ein wachsames auge haben und natürlich
wie auch bei verträgen ins
kleingedruckte schauen auch bei
wahlumfragen und behaltet folgendes im
kopf passiert differenziert und trübe
und ausführlich ist es meistens ein
ausdruck davon dass sich da jemand
differenziert ist seriös gedanken
gemacht hat was mir ist ganz wichtig ist
zu sagen ist umfragen müssen überhaupt
nicht langweilig sein gib mir doch bitte
mal recht wir haben ja schließlich der
kanzel videoreihe hier dazu mehr findet
ihr auch hier neben mir da geht es darum
warum umfragen bei der afg oft daneben
liegen und darunter noch im video der
kollegen die nutella magnetische unter
die lupe nehmen sowie einen link zu den
aktuellen politbarometer ergebnissen
unten in der infobox umfragen können
unglaublich spannend sein kann muss sie
aber ganz kritisch betrachten und man
sollte nicht alles sofort glauben mit
diesem kleinen appell vielen dank fürs
zuschauen und bis zum nächsten mal